now that rule is the coach in carolina
the first question is going to be
what does he do with the most important
job on the field does he want cam newton
who is still a very good quarterback but
can't stay healthy yeah no i uh i mean i
would want cam newton i would if i'm
matt rule i don't know what his thoughts
are here i got no inside info now do you
want cam newton and then start going
okay we also have to think of the future
or
maybe finding another backup that's a
similar skill set to cam newton in case
he does get hurt maybe you're happy with
what you have there already with kyle
allen i don't know but you know i
understand cam newton banged up and
things like that i get it and he's
getting at that age where you start to
wonder will it be an every year type of
thing but this is a guy that seems to
have great pride in taking care of his
body he's a great competitor and he's
got great talent and there's just not a
lot of people out there that you can say
all those things about with cam newton
he's a special special talent and i
would think if he wants to get this
thing off in the right way you'd keep
cam newton stay in the good graces of
the fans of charlotte and carolina
panthers in general and you try to build
something around him here for one last
push in his career
there's a lot of factors that are going
to go into that decision one of which
will be whether into what extent they
get trade offers from other teams and
there will be plenty of quarterbacks
available in free agency so i don't know
what kind of an offer they may get from
a team like the charters which i think
would be perfect for cam newton for
football and for business reasons but i
think that's part of it matt rule has to
look at this very dispassionately this
is a business decision what do we get
out of cam newton as a player if we keep
him and the salary for 2020 is very
affordable if cam newton is not banging
on the door for a contract extension 19
million i think is the total payout
that's nothing in comparison to the top
of the market but but that makes it more
tradable too and could make him more
attractive to another team so i think
you play at coy
and you sit back and you wait and you
see what happens but ultimately the
preferences of matt rule will be a
factor does he want cam newton does he
want someone else and that's the first
big decision most important position on
the field and rule's going to have to
decide what his vision is for the
offense and also short term long term
right do you want one year with cam
newton do you want more than one year
would you rather start building with
someone else that's the i think that's
where you you you got me thinking here
and yeah you're right i mean we're
talking about yeah maybe building
something else with a guy who's famous
for rebuilding right
so maybe that is the play you know now
that you sit here and you continue to
digest this maybe it is you know yeah
play coy
maybe get a king's ransom in a trade and
that helps you start your rebuild or
however the vision of your team is so
there's some different angles here he
certainly has some options and that's
always good as a head coach there's
talent on the roster yet some assets to
play with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports